welcome back to the five we are
answering your questions this Memorial
Day and now for my list of questions
um I'll start with you Tom if you could
be on any game show that you could what
would that game show be I would say the
uh I you know I love Jeopardy but I
would never go on here because I'd be
embarrassed you have to be smart
what's that I did Jeopardy for charity
and it was the most humiliating most
nerve-wracking thing of my life if you
blame it on the on the plunger that's
what they did all of it but also I also
my mind so I do Wheel of Fortune I'm
pretty good with the words oh you are
okay and Dana I would do 100 000 pyramid
okay which used to be twenty five
thousand dollar pyramid but with
inflation inflation yeah I've always
wanted to do that with Greg because I
thought that we would win so I saw
Michael Strahan the other day he's now
the host yeah and I S and they remember
they used to come here for Thursday
Night Football I haven't seen them in a
while and I said do you ever do a
charity thing Greg and I are in there I
don't know if Greg still wants to do it
with me but that was my goal yeah all
right Jesse I want to do prices right oh
it seems like a lot of luck and that's
what you need on a show like that I
don't want any Battle of the wits and
being exposed on National Television I
want to do blinko or you just drop it or
yeah I want to do one dollar yeah and
get it right and then take my chance at
that spin that looks like that for going
back to school I don't remember you're
doing such a great job do you shop a lot
no no I don't
know all right
better than
um in the shut up
go ahead I'd like to do Family Feud with
my own family but we were trying out the
other day on air we could do like a five
to take on The View yeah and for charity
it'd be awesome I've always wanted to do
that that hot new show that Jesse Jesse
introduced America too we were watching
the five and Jesse this show yeah what
was that
no one had ever seen it Steve Harvey
that Steve Harvey was the original host
and it was stay home from school and
just watch TV no not that show I love
Family Feud I definitely agree I would
do that plus I'll have Steve Harvey okay
did any of you ever ride fan mail to a
favorite movie star musician sports star
Jessica
I don't
think so no fan mail no not no okay
Jesse
no I didn't
I think I might have written Trump a
note congratulating him on his 2016
election yeah is that fan mail uh I
think it's definitely what did you say I
said great job
I said thanks for making Waters world
number one yeah yeah with those rallies
that's right eight o'clock I remember
that Dana I don't remember anything like
that except for
and if politicians count I don't know I
sent a letter to President Reagan once
yeah got a nice little note back
probably Auto penned but I liked it yeah
okay so after the decathlon win I called
Bruce Jenner on the radio you did I got
through and uh I asked some advice about
uh running and working out yeah what'd
he tell you he said uh hey I need a new
coach yeah you know any joke like that
he said hey you know I'm looking for a
new trainer and you know I thought he
was serious I turned to my mom and I
said how can I apply she said he was
just kidding I don't think he was
kidding
okay you know who I wrote to I was 15
years old I wrote to this famous lawyer
at the time and I just watched him on uh
on my phone uh a guy by the name of Jake
Ehrlich he was like his famous trial
lawyer and do you know a 15 years old
I'm not going to count but I still have
his photo he sent me his photo it went
through a flawed it got crushed in the
flood and I pulled it out but Jake here
like he was my hero that reminds me I
actually did write uh O.J Simpson fan
mail before the murder trial yeah it was
a big fan of his good clarification did
you get Alexa without back yeah I got a
note back could we get a handwriting
sample yeah see before the murder trial
or before the murder yeah I hope it
wasn't in between those two okay how
many times do you hit the snooze alarm
none I don't operate on an alarm system
you just I'm so paranoid about the time
that I have to get up
and I don't if you're paranoid why
wouldn't you guarantee that no because
I'm up I'm like nervous from like an
hour before I'm supposed to get up isn't
that interesting my therapist thinks so
yeah yeah all right Tom do you hear the
snooze I when I lived with my
grandmother when I went to college she
lived near my college campus so I lived
with her for a year and she would not
allow alarm clocks in her house why used
one up until then she said we don't use
alarm clocks in this house we pray you
say a prayer you tell God when you want
to wake up he will wake you up I did it
it worked it worked I've never used an
alarm George Bush is like that yeah all
right Dana I never hit the snooze alarm
because I feel like that would be yeah
you know like that'd be a demerit yes
and I don't like that but I have one of
those alarm clocks now the hatch alarm
clock that gradually gets light and I
swear by it it's excellent because
there's no noise right it's not jarring
when it wakes up it's nice
to wake up at 4 30 or whatever yeah but
he does get up then he walks the dog
you're supposed to take your alarm clock
and put it far across the room so you
actually have to physically get up to
turn it off so you can't just roll over
and hit the button I put it across the
room yeah I do that and Emma goes and
gets it I do that and when I lived with
my grandmother in college when I would
have women over
I would not
believe you lived with your grandmother
in college
are you done
with him I'm just getting started all
right
um you know what I do I have an alarm
and I have like music that fires me up
so as soon as it goes I'm dancing out of
bed at that point we need to calm you
down okay no you don't I'm very calm
one word that best describes you as a
child I want to hear this from you Jesse
first rambunctious rambunctious Dana one
word obedient
perfect Tom my fourth grade teacher used
to call me a nuclear physicist I don't
know why she would say that that's not
one word well smart not that smart uh
yeah I mean I was precocious I wasn't
really smart and and wasn't really a
good student because she thought how
about you
determined okay my sister said funny
that I was funny I believe that yeah
can't do better than that yeah okay are
you a dessert person an appetizer person
or an appetizer person when you go out
to dinner dessert 100 so you'll skip the
appetizer or you do all three I'll do it
all but I'll most enjoy dessert yeah and
I never skip it
I don't like to choose either but if I
had to choose I'm Pro appetizer really
see men are so lucky like that don't you
have a sweet tooth there I do have a
sweet tooth but I'm also hungry yeah
yeah well you could be hungry and eat
dessert that doesn't fill you up you're
right you can get a lot of food in an
appetizer you can get like a half
portion of pasta right in the appetizer
has the meal you do okay Dana I like the
appetizer because I'm usually I always
like if I could eat dinner at 5 PM I
would I'll when I finally go wherever
I'm going to go in the future five
o'clock Blue Plate special I'll be there
I'll save a lot of money okay for me I'd
rather eat the appetizer I'd rather eat
dessert than the appetizer or dinner I
start the dessert okay last question
what snack item do you always have at
home
tortilla chips
pistachios
peeled or do you peel them I don't peel
salted or unsalted not lightly okay
popcorn
I steal the Nutter Butters from Fox News
and I take them home
so we have
we'll answer that and much more on our
Memorial Day fan mail special when we
return hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to
Seaway that I know for sure that you're
not going to miss any great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on Fox you
can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now